the reason why i spent seven years
running this entrepreneurship non-profit
is i saw the numbers around declining
entrepreneurship around the country and
i thought that's a disaster
and it was a disaster in terms of jobs
and opportunities
and the economy but it was also disaster
socially or culturally
because i had been formed myself like
you as the
head of this small business and you're
allowed to be a human being as a head of
a small business you know you're allowed
to do things that are frankly not
economically optimal um just because you
feel like it
because you're you know you like that
person in your case you were like guess
what i'm gonna pay you all 70k
it's like what i could have hired you
for 40k who cares i'm gonna pay you 70k
because i think it's the right thing to
do
and i think writ large um you know will
benefit from it but also
i just feel like it and
like the yeah and there's like this
market logic
that over uh overrides everything
if you're part of a very large
corporation where you're not allowed to
do anything that's
um economically irrational and thus
human
yeah well and and the problem with that
is it's creating a level
of conformity where everyone's doing the
same thing i mean if you look at a lot
of the decisions that i've made
made and continue to make their
decisions that i
learned through all these various like
ceo learning organizations peer-to-peer
learning organizations and just
a lot of business books you know
everything out there
is like there's only one way to do
things i mean a pretty recent example is
like when the pandemic hit we lost 55
percent of our revenue because our 20
000 small business clients
lost 55 percent of their revenue and our
revenue turns out is an exact function
of theirs
yeah and so basically you know what
we're taught
and what you were taught i'm sure as
well in a lot of these same circles
is you want to do a very hard cut
layoff early so that you can have a
recovery story you want to cut deeper
than you need to
and then the next day you're you're back
on the front foot you're back to hiring
you're back to growth
and you protect your balance sheet
you're willing to sacrifice the people
that got you
here to protect your balance sheet and
then turn around and
potentially bring new people on board or
or save the company or whatnot and so
we're just taught in situations like
this and you see it all over with
hertz and jcpenney and you know i did
like a twitter thread even of like
bankrupt companies that are doing all
these layoffs giving huge bonuses to the
ceos
or big companies uh like one of my
competitors toast
they just raised 300 million dollars on
a multi-billion dollar valuation
and right afterwards they laid off 50 of
their team right after doing that
and so we're just kind of taught that
this is the only way of doing it
and it's hard but i think when people
make different decisions like we did we
said we're not going to lay anybody off
we're going to find a way to get through
this together
there's actually a lot more benefit
there than people realize it's more
viable
and i think we're proving that every day
but yet kind of the orthodoxy if you
just go around talking to people at
cocktail parties
or reading the books or whatnot we're
just told there's only one way to do it
and it's clearly wrong so it kind of
begs the question
why are we being told that um i think
that we've
convinced ourselves that people are not
good that people are bad
and capital and corporations are good
and i think if you look at the data that
i'm seeing in the experience
i have it's exactly the opposite i mean
when we got hit by the pandemic our
employees said
we don't want anyone laid off and we
don't want any increased fees or
decreased service for our small business
clients
and they got together they asked for my
permission took some time got together
and they said we don't want anyone to
get an involuntary pay cut because
maybe somebody just had somebody else
get laid off or had schools
uh interrupted and all of a sudden
expenses went up so they said we're
gonna
we're gonna do we're gonna try to get
together and do an anonymous
voluntary complete restructuring where
people take anonymous pay cuts
and we had 98 of the company asked to
take a pay cut
anonymously just through this like code
of like number this person
and then they turn around pivoted and
started working with
20 000 small businesses that trust
gravity to get them reopen
and putting all these solutions into
place they did things like
come up with like this app where like
coffee shops can have starbucks
type order head coffee where
veterinarians can move the front desk to
the car
because we've sent a text message that
opens up and they can close out their
folio
and they pivot and did all these things
and we're not going to make money for a
while and i'm okay
with that but we're going to survive
we're going to be able to keep helping
these small businesses as long as
they're still around to be helped
and i think that's an example where it
was shocking to me because when the
employees pitch that to me is how we're
going to recover
as a ceo it just went against everything
i was ever taught and everything all of
us are taught which is
we try to sell each other out we try to
hurt each other but that is the behavior
of corporations
and if we can actually empower people
and and in some ways disempower
corporations or at least spread out the
power a little bit
we're gonna see more and more of that
and i think because the corporations
are so bad people come across as bad if
you deal with like a com
cast customer service rep they seem like
a genuinely bad person the reality is
that person would do a fantastic job
they're a really good person
if they weren't being so mistreated by
the system and by their employer
and so i think that the the cause for
optimism that i have is
we actually don't need to change people
we just need to change the system and
the structure
around people take away what's
constraining them and then
people and then people will actually
save us but we have to actually
do it and that's the hard part yeah we
have to overrun
uh like the corporate system to give
people a chance to bring out the best in
ourselves
um and i 100 agree with you that
people if you believe in them uh like
they
expand it's well like you believed in
your people
and then they believed in themselves and
then when
dark times come they look around and say
okay we can do something about this
like you know i'm not going to wait for
like the boss to come and tell us what's
up
it's like you know like i care about you
i care about myself
like you know let's try and solve for
this
but a lot of it was because you created
that environment and you believed in
them
you know the reverse is true too that if
you're part of an organization where
they treat you like [ __ ] all the time
you know
like dark times come that you'll be like
oh no like like one i know they're gonna
get rid of me if they can and two like
maybe i'll like throw my colleague under
the bus because it's gonna be like me or
them and like you know like that
like the and most americans
unfortunately are laboring under like
the latter type of
situation or environment because of the
corporate logic you're talking about
it's like if you had enough human
leaders like yourself
creating cultures where people believed
in each other
and ourselves and cared about each other
then you could solve these problems
well and i think that's why it's so
important to get messages out there like
i worked so hard trying to get this
story out there
and people are like why do you do it
it's like well if these stories can get
out
people can see like people ask me all
the time how do you motivate your team
i'm like i don't try to motivate them i
try to not demotivate them
like i'm the bad guy in this equation
they're actually do they they will do
great job just on their own and most
people will out there
and so if we can take away that and
invest instead in people's
capability and give them actual license
and power
and but i feel like what we have to do
is connect the dots between what you see
happening at gravity the story i'm out
there sharing
and what you're saying because we can
look at these as
experiments when we do what you're
proposing in small settings
companies flourish or at a very minimum
they still do okay like i'm still here
i'm still happy i'm still doing fine
and it's not like the entire the lie
we've been told is that the entire
economy and all of our jobs will go away
if we hold big companies accountable if
we put people first and the opposite is
true
as a whole we will thrive now will some
people be less wealthy
absolutely and that's fine because when
jeff bezos comes out and says
he has to start a space company because
he has so much money
it's the only thing where he can
possibly spend even a tiny percentage of
his money that he cares about
that's a signal of like hey actually he
could take that same amount of money
and he could pay 250 000 people that
work in his warehouse as a living wage
those people could then invest in their
skills and they could get better
opportunities not be held back
and those shifts if we can find a way to
harness
some of these stories and some of the
data that we're seeing
i think the proof is already there i
just think we have to get the word out
and then we'll be able to fix this
it's beyond vital it's central
uh you know if you imagine a world where
everyone's working for amazon
which that world is happening i don't
know if you all can sense it i mean
if if you look at the amazon employee
count like it's shooting up just as all
of retail is closing so no it's not one
for one unfortunately like it's not like
for every male worker like they're
hiring an amazon worker they eliminate
five jobs and make one
and they say they're job creators yeah
yeah and then they go around being like
hey
look at look at the jobs we created like
uh you know we've got
like all this good pr around it and
we're gonna yell at you about all the
jobs we created it's like hey
like if you looked at the retail sector
you're like you know that thing used to
employ
11 million people you employ 11 million
people in amazon
like no but we we employ you know
whatever they employ like hundreds of
thousands
uh it's heartbreaking too to see the way
they put the computers
in charge of the humans at amazon that
is really horrific to see and there's
you know there was that frontline
documentary about
this with amazon but basically like
they're the people the computers tell
them what to do
and they want the people to act with the
same ruthless form of efficiency
that the robots and computers do and
that's really horrific and heartbreaking
to
see because it dehumanizes those people
that are working
then when you don't pay a living wage
you know it dehumanizes their home life
so they have their work life dehumanized
and their home life dehumanized at the
same time
my friends at amazon are very open they
say you know we're always just trying to
automate our own jobs away like that's
just the culture of the
the org it's like an efficiency engine
that place
uh and um i mean that's from jeff on
down
like jeff sort of like a like a zealot
when it comes to
you know trying to get things done as
efficiently as possible and that filters
down
pretty pretty quickly uh and the
antidote really is
people going out and doing what they
want to do in their community in the
form of a small business and then
treating
their employees well treating their
customers while treating themselves
well last because in my experience small
business owners like have to look out
for themselves after they look out for
everyone else under the sun
but that's that's the our only chance
really uh like this is the giant
rebalancing i was concerned about
and now pandemic has sped us up so the
stuff that
that that andrew yang like you know
chicken little dystopian figure like uh
you know all of a sudden it's with us
right now um i'm with you on being very
very concerned about the timing dan
it's like like like this stuff is
mission critical and needs to get passed
yesterday and we don't have that much
time
i mean in my case i'm obviously pushing
for
a change in leadership and i hope that
if you had
let's say one party in charge of
congress and
the white house they could get massive
solutions across the the goal line
that could hopefully help preserve a lot
of these small businesses and these jobs
and the humans who have dedicated
years decades of their their lives to
building them in many many cases
and that's the other part of it too is
that like if you dedicate decades of
your life to something and then you see
it
uh disintegrate
you know like that that's devastating
yeah it's crushing and we
we need i mean right now we're you know
congress is in recess and we need
some type of relief for everyday people
for small businesses like we need to do
something and i just am like you know
like we
we don't want to see this change happen
because it's going to be very hard to
undo
when so many of our small businesses are
going under
as someone who's run a small business
you know it's not like you can flip a
switch
you know like your employees all drift
off and find other opportunities like
your vendors
uh you know close down the line like you
sell the
equipment or furniture like you know you
can't just be like and i'm back
in a lot of these cases well and the
small businesses
make those individual choices as you
highlighted earlier
that are more human they're more in line
with the human-centric economy that
you've been championing that i've been
championing because
you know they go out there they know
those people they're not making the
they're not making the decision only
based on what they saw in their business
school class or what the spreadsheet
says they actually know the decisions
they make how they impact
real people and so if we want to make
our
our
economy more efficient at and ruthless
at making all of our lives
worse all we need to do is completely
get dominated by all these large
companies and monopolies and if we want
to stop that from happening
we basically need to sell out and do
whatever we need to to protect these
small businesses
because they really are kind of as the
bible says you know a little bit of salt
goes a long way they
are the salt for our economy for our
communities having those small
businesses still be around
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode
[Music]
you